growing at five or seven percent today
is the equivalent in absolute value of
ten to twelve percent five years ago so
thinking that China has a problem
growing at five or seven percent I don't
understand China is still a growing
market and seven percent growth in China
could be compared with two to two to
three percent growth in America and we
are very happy when I mega grow as two
to three percent so now I'm very very
confident the stabilization period was
necessary after such a growth are you
slowing though new store openings in
China this year the point is that on the
net basis openings closings it will it
will slow down the reason being for
instance for Gucci that one specific
phenomenon in China is the fact that the
the city geography in terms of Commerce
is not stabilized meaning that a good
location three years ago might not be so
good three years after which is not the
case anywhere else in the world so we
need to be very flexible that is the
sounds least exactly 5th Avenue is 5th
Avenue Shanghai Beijing is completely
different so you need to integrate that
in the way you do business and and we
decided to cope with that for it's been
a year and a half now to make sure that
we always have the best network of
stores in that country so we are now
relocating some stores changing modes
when it's necessary so you need to make
sure that you are in the right place at
the right moment globally what can you
reveal to us on how you are going to
restore the momentum for Gucci the
fourth quarter as you know the weakest
sales growth since the third quarter of
2009 that was an exceptional year 2009
as the global financial crisis was
happening what's happening now with
Gucci and how are you going to write
whatever is going wrong if it's going
wrong no no we are in the middle of our
of our implementation of the strategy
which is and it's all the big brands of
the same challenge how do you remain
exclusive and and on the same time
continue to grow this is some
the phrenic situation there we don't
believe that luxury brands can take
advantage of all the price segments by
stretching the brand vertically like
very low price 200 euros towards 5000
euros in the same category we don't
believe in that so we need to move
upwards as the number of customers
capable of buying luxury products is
increasing in the world this as an
impact on sales but that absolutely what
we wanted to do so I'm not authority I
know that the financial market are I
have some question about the slow the
slowing growth of Gucci it's what we
want if the growth was based on selling
more and more we were pleased everyone
but this will be the greatest danger for
the brand so it's very important that we
move upwards how about on the other end
of the spectrum where are you in the
transformation of Puma in lifestyle
sports it sounds like this year perhaps
next year as well is the makeup break
here for program yeah first line end of
this year for sure okay we will know
implementation execution of the strategy
is the other key and this is what we
missed over the last four years at Puma
and I'm pretty sure that we will correct
that you can grab some of that market
share from Nike and Adidas the much
bigger players the market is growing so
I will get market share from other
players for sure but the market is
growing this is very important luxury
and sports are structurally over the
long period of time growing markets so
this is why the group has this very
strong potential worldwide